[موسيقى]
مواصفات طبخ غريبه ومواد تجميل اضافه الى
نصائح الموضه هذا المحتوى الذي يقدمه
تطبيق لمن ايت الوافد الجديد على منصات
التواصل الاجتماعي الذي اطلقته شركه
المالكه لتطبيق تيك توك في امريكا مؤخرا
بعد اطلاقه في اليابان عام 2020
وقد تم تنزيله سته عشر مليون مره الى الان
عن هذا التطبيق في امريكا تزامنا مع
الضغوط الكبيره التي تعرضت لها شركه تيك
توك في الدول الغربيه فقد تم استجواب
مديرها التنفيذي شاوزي تشو امام الكونجرس
بخصوص مخاوف حول امن وخصوصيه المعلومات
حيث تشك واشنطن ومعها عواصم غربيه اخرى في
ان بكين تستطيع الوصول لمعلومات مستخدمي
تيك توك في امريكا والغرب وقد تستعملها في
جمع معلومات استخباراتيه تطبيق لمن ايت
الذي وصل الى المركز التاسع بين العشره
الاوائل في متجر التطبيقات الامريكي قد
يكون حسب مراقبين مناوره قامت بها بعد
دانس للبقاء في السوق الامريكي في حال
صدور قرار بمنع تيك توك بشكل نهائي انس
نماسي العربيه